bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à bruxelles au coeur du parlement
européen pour cette nouvelle édition d'
europe hebdo cette semaine je vous
emmène en grèce dans la région d'athènes
nous sommes retournés dans le pays pour
voir si le parti de la gauche radicale
syriza arrivée au pouvoir il ya quatre
mois a pu tenir ses promesses de
campagne qu'en est il nous sommes allés
à la rencontre des heureux et des déçus
de syriza c'est le reportage d' europe
hebdo à voir dans un instant mais
d'abord l'actualité avec le vent du
changement qui souffle en espagne les
élections municipales et régionales ont
sonné comme un vote sanction pour la
droite au pouvoir et donner sa chance au
mouvement podemos regarder ce petit
résumé en images on en parle avec votre
invité dans un instant
deux visages deux femmes qui incarne le
changement politique en espagne manuela
carmena 71 ans cette juge à la retraite
sera peut-être la prochaine maire de
madrid obama nous allons convaincre ceux
qui ne croient pas au changement pour
qu'il se rende compte comme ça peut être
merveilleux de changer de changer en
mieux pour une ville plus juste
à dakola aux 41 ans se prépare quant à
elles à prendre la mairie de barcelone
c'est la victoire de david contre
goliath
la victoire de la citoyenneté de
l'espérance de l'an viii du changement
contre la peur contre la campagne de
résignation et c'est la victoire de tout
le monde et de tout barcelone où tom
watson
les candidates sont toutes les deux
soutenus par podemos la formation de la
gauche radicale issu du mouvement des
indignés un vote synonyme de sanction
pour la droite au pouvoir en espagne le
parti populaire est sur le point de
perdre la capitale qu'il dirige depuis
24 ans les électeurs ont exprimé leur
ras-le-bol des politiques d'austérité et
de la corruption qui affecte le parti au
pouvoir même révolution en vue à
barcelone ou à dakola au est arrivé
devant les nationalistes catalans mais
pour gouverner les deux femmes vont
devoir négocier et s'allier avec
d'autres partis de gauche notamment les
socialistes espagnols qui accusent aussi
le coup quatre ans après l'apparition du
mouvement des indignés est ce la fin du
bipartisme en espagne le pays s'engage t
il sur une troisième voie politique
nous accueillons sur ce plateau yannick
jadot bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être là vous êtes député européen élu
ici au groupe des verts alliance libre
européenne alors vous êtes membre de la
commission du commerce international on
parlera tout à l'heure d'un dossier
sensible qui vous concerne le traité
transatlantique mais d'abord l'actualité
votre commentaire sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en espagne alors je vous ai
vu un peu cligner des yeux pendant le
reportage est ce que au sujet de podemos
est ce que pour vous podemos est
derrière ces deux candidates qui
s'apprête à remporter deux villes en
espagne est ce que c'est la même chose
ce qui est étonnant c'est la perception
qu'on a de l'extérieur de l'espagne ce
qui se passe réellement en espagne on a
partout une incroyable dynamique des
candidatures citoyenne en espagne toutes
les femmes que vous avez montré manuela
carmena à dakola haut pour barcelone ou
encore monica oltra pour valence ce sont
des femmes le plus souvent issus de la
société civile qui ont construit une
candidature soutenue par des partis
politiques
il ya effectivement podemos est ce que
c'est la non ça n'est pas la victoire de
condé moss et c'est même d'une certaine
façon une remise en cause de la
stratégie de podemos le résultat de ces
élections parce que par exemple à
valence la candidature citoyenne
soutenue par les écologistes et
régionalistes et passer devant podemos à
madrid comme à barcelone pour des
mosfets fait évidemment partie de la
coalition mais pas seulement et en fait
la victoire de dimanche ces victoires
que vous avez présenté c'est une
victoire d'une très large coalition
autour de candidature citoyenne et là où
ça pose un problème d'ailleurs pourquoi
demos c'est podemos un moment s'est vue
être la troisième voie évidente refusant
le parti populaire refusant le parti
socialiste est éteint l'alternative au
fond ce que cette élection a démontré
ses podemos ne peut pas être
l'alternative seuls ils ont à travailler
avec l'ensemble de la société civile
avec d'autres formations politiques dont
les ailes dont les verts elles ont fait
de très bons scores en espagne et ça
c'est la bonne nouvelle en espagne c'est
que justement il n'y a pas ce fantasme
d'un parent six recours d'un parti
providentiel autour d'une personnalité
forte qui eglesias mais c'est beaucoup
plus vaste dans la société c'est
beaucoup plus dynamique que ça parce que
ce que vous n'osiez de notre titre c'est
une troisième voie politique pour
l'espagne donc vous dites que cette
troisième voie existe entre les
socialistes et entre la droite au
pouvoir et les socialistes ya une
troisième voie mais qu'elle ne passe pas
forcément par peur des mots elle passe
avec podemos avec mais beaucoup plus
largement podemos et on le voit dans les
coalitions qui vont devoir se construire
cela devra se faire aussi avec le parti
socialiste parce que le parti socialiste
ne s'est pas écroulé on n'est pas dans
un scénario à la grecque avec le pasok
qui est totalement détruit on est sur
des coalitions qui sont en train de se
construire et c'est ça qui est
intéressant parce qu'au fond ils vont
devoir construire ces coalitions devant
les citoyens ils vont devoir dire quels
sont les termes de l'accord et on sait
que c'est ça aussi comme ça se passe
dans beaucoup de pays grâce à la
proportionnelle c'est ça aussi qu'il
donne de la force au programme politique
c'est que à force de négocier devant les
citoyens eh bien une fois qu'on met les
réformes en place les citoyens les
accepte c'est un peu le contraire de ce
qui se passe en france mais alors il ya
beaucoup de rêves dans vie de révolution
beaucoup de mots comme ça qu'ils sont
qui sont prononcés mais face à la
réalité de l'exercice du pouvoir dans
ces régions qui sont d'ailleurs très
endetté est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
plate forme citoyenne qui ont porté ces
deux candidates à madrid et à barcelone
sont capables de mettre au point un
programme de gouvernement solide c'est
tout le défi c'est tout le défi du
moment qui vient parce que ce sont des
candidatures encore une fois des
candidatures citoyenne issus de la
société civile de combat extrêmement
important dans la société ils vont il ya
beaucoup de personnel politique nouveau
qui va arriver
ça c'est des femmes des femmes dans un
pays qu'on considère souvent machiste à
vous sauvez le de trois ans de débats
sautel l'espagne c'était le retour sur
le droit à l'avortement donc c'est
extrêmement important mais ça va être
mais à barcelone par exemple à la colle
à eau est une femme qui s'est tellement
battu sur la précarité dans le logement
que l'inde est la première grande mesure
la première grande priorité ce sera un
travail sur le logement sur la
rénovation thermique pour faire des
économies pour les populations et puis
offrir un logement décent à tout le
monde mais c'est vrai que le défi c
est-ce qu'ils vont être capables de
gérer est-ce qu'ils vont être capables
de gérer de répondre une telle attente
mais c'est tout le bien qu'on peut leur
souhaiter alors yannick jadot
l'actualité aussi alors internationale
avec cette opération navale qui se
prépare qui semble se préparer en
méditerranée objectif intercepter les
bateaux des passeurs qui font leur
commerce sur le dos des migrants des
réfugiés état des lieux de la mission
avec le chef de la diplomatie européenne
on en parle
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
m'ont demandé le mois dernier de
préparer une action de politique commune
en matière de sécurité et de défense
cette opération vise au démantèlement
des réseaux de passeurs en conformité
avec le droit international
nous espérons que l'opération sera prête
à être lancée dès le mois de juin mais
cela dépendra principalement des états
membres
c'était la déclaration faite par
federica mot guérini il ya une semaine
est ce que aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on
en ait et vous est-ce que vous soutenez
cette opération ce que c'est une bonne
réponse ce n'est pas une réponse
suffisante
est-ce qu'il faut lutter contre les
trafiquants bien sûr mais vous savez
quand des populations pendant des mois
parfois des années ont traversé des
déserts se sont fait racketter violente
et les femmes violées au prix parfois de
leur vie ou de la vie de leurs proches
ils sont arrivés jusqu'en libye si on
empêche des bateaux et ben ces migrants
pas ce qui c'est une question de survie
vont trouver des voies encore plus
périlleuse encore plus longue pour
essayer de rejoindre le territoire
européen donc en fait qu'il fallait
lutter contre les trafiquants bien sûr
parce qu'au fond c'est terrible mais on
est en train de casser le symptômes sans
s'attaquer aux causes pourquoi il ya une
telle déstabilisation à tel chaos au
moyen-orient pourquoi il ya un tel chaos
en afrique du nord et on sait que les
européens ont été impliqués dans ce
chaos la grande-bretagne et la pologne
les deux premiers pays à refuser des
quotas de réfugiés sont deux pays qui
ont participé à la coalition bush
camille le chaos absolu en irak et en
syrie et au fond vous voyez on a on est
on à ddd des centaines de milliers six
cent mille huit cent mille réfugiés en
jordanie 1 million liban huit cent mille
en turquie et on est en train de se dire
que notre affaire c'est de lutter contre
les trafiquants pour ne pas avoir
accepté notre part de responsabilité
même part de protection de réfugiés qui
ont terriblement besoin alors on vous
entend bien et en même temps on constate
le moc de solidarité européenne puisque
seuls quelques pays se partagent le
fardeau si je puis dire de l'accueil
comment vous faites pour convaincre les
autres la grande majorité l'immense
majorité des pays européens qui ne
veulent pas qu'ils ne sont pas
accueillants il faut arriver à 10 la
vérité sur ces réfugiés il faut arriver
à dire la vérité sur les migrants
aujourd'hui on a des gouvernements qui
sont tétanisés par leur extrême droite
et qui joue l'égoïsme et le repli
national dans toute l'histoire est
compris dans l'histoire européenne il ya
eu des réfugiés on a besoin vous avez
des gens qui sont en état de survie qui
fuient la dictature qui fuient la misère
qui fuient l'oppression on ne peut pas
dire dans un pays en france de 65
millions d'habitants qui est un des pays
les plus riches certes la richesse est
inégalement répartis mais qui est un des
pays les plus riches on peut pas
accepter plus de 2006 rien c'est
totalement absurde donc il faut dire la
vérité il faut dire que de toute façon
ces migrants comme ils veulent survivre
ils trouveront toujours un moyen
d'arriver que notre rôle notre
responsabilité nos obligations c'est la
protection et qu'on doit s'interroger
sur ce qu'on a fait en irak on doit
s'interroger sur ce qu'on a vu en syrie
on doit s'interroger sur ce qu'on a fait
en libye la france ne peut pas vendre
des armes dans tout le moyen-orient et
s'étonner que soutenir des dictatures et
s'étonner que quand tout ça s'effondre
c'est le chaos et que ça crie ça crée
des réfugiés alors une dernière question
yannick jadot absurde arrive au terme de
cette édition mais on peut pas ne pas me
parler d'un dossier sensible est urgent
que vous êtes en train de négocier ici
au parlement européen le fameux traité
transatlantique qui en voie de signature
entre les états unis et l'europe on
n'entend pas beaucoup parler où en sont
les négociations pour l'instant les
négociations sont un peu bloquée parce
qu'au fond la priorité des américains
c'est négociait khl pacifique ce n'est
pas négocier avec l'europe et puis vous
savez on a un débat très important
maintenant en europe sur ces questions
là il yal'affaire des tribunaux ou
tribunaux privé qui erraient au delà nos
juridictions et ça c'est une nouvelle
chance pour vous abbas est terrible
c'est une terrible nouvelle l'idée qu'on
privatise la justice l'idée que des
multinationales
parce que des états ont pris des mesures
en matière de santé de protection de
l'environnement des droits sociaux les
multinationales pourraient les attaquer
devant des tribunaux privée où se sont
pas des juges qui siègent mais des
avocats d'affaires et les états
pourraient être condamnés à des
milliards d'euros de dédommagements
tenons c'est totalement absurde dans le
monde aujourd'hui continuer à donner de
plus en plus de pouvoir des
multinationales contre nos droits contre
notre démocratie c'est une absurdité
donc le débat se poursuit et j'espère
que les citoyens européens continueront
à se mobiliser eh ben on en parlera avec
vous prochainement dans cette émission
merci beaucoup yannick jadot d'avoir été
notre invité je vous propose de regarder
tout de suite notre reportage il ya
quatre mois series à la gauche radicale
arrivé au pouvoir en grèce après
l'élection triomphale de son chef alexis
tsipras ce qui promettait à ses
électeurs et à bruxelles d'en finir avec
l'austérité où en est-on nous sommes
retournés sur place pour voir si les
choses avaient changé c'est un reportage
de jean baptiste daoulas
plus jeune plus décontractés ils sont
les nouveaux visages du pouvoir en grèce
il y a un an reina doro devenait l'une
des élues locales les plus puissants du
pays à la tête d'une région de 4
millions d'habitants elle arrive avec
une mesure choc contre la crise
reconnecter tous les foyers où
l'électricité a été coupée
électricité pour tous on met un filet de
sécurité pour protéger les personnes ou
frappés par la crise humanitaire il
s'agit de retrouver de la croissance
parce que nous ne pouvons pas avoir de
la croissance si la société et éprouve à
documents
une centaine de foyers reconnecter dix
mille autres où le courant ne sera pas
coupé grâce à une aide financière de la
région le programme électricité pour
tous est symbolique mais il a un coût
deux millions et demi d'euros par an
syriza a peu de moyens financiers pour
changer la vie des grecs dans ce
dispensaire de la banlieue d'athènes il
y a toujours autant de personnes en
difficulté
je mets salins et ça servira à celui qui
en a besoin
d'après
dionysia et ses amis et peluches des
légumes bientôt périmé fournis
gratuitement par une grande surface au
chômage depuis cinq ans divorcée depuis
l'an dernier elle a encore trop de
ressources pour profiter du programme
électricité pour tous
moi aussi je risque de rentrer chez moi
un soir et de voir ma maison plongée
dans le noir sans eau ni électricité ni
rien du tout je dois encore 670 euros de
factures d'électricité et 150 euros de
factures d'eau et d'un côté les choses
sont vraiment très difficile
tous les jours je vois venir des gens
qui avaient une situation une famille et
maintenant ils viennent frapper à la
porte ici
l'arrivée au pouvoir de syriza n'a rien
changé au quotidien du dispensaire
ce sont les chants qui attendent la
distribution de nourriture
mais ici on reste bienveillant avec le
gouvernement
il y a eu comme un courant d'optimisme
avec type race on était tous portés par
ce courant sipera c'est devenu très
populaire pareil pour yannis varoufakis
mais il ya des limites on leur laisse un
certain laps de temps mais s'ils ne font
pas ce qu'il faut on va se rebeller on
n'a vraiment pas d'autre choix
le bénéfice du doute series elle a déjà
perdu sur le port du pirée en janvier le
gouvernement si traces avaient bloqué la
privatisation du site mais le projet et
vient d'être relancé pour donner des
gages aux créanciers du pays
avec l'extension de la privatisation
tout ce morceau la partie avec les
paquebots et la partie dédiée aux
passagers la totalité du port sera donné
à la société privée qui va l'acquérir
en janvier beaucoup d'ouvriers du port
pensait enterré la privatisation en
votant pour ses riverains ici on avait
négocié des conditions de travail
décentes mais maintenant notre futur
c'est l'insécurité pour tous
dans un laps de temps court vraiment
très très court il s'est avéré que le
gouvernement actuel a menti au peuple
grec en fait ils continuent exactement
sur la voie qui avait tracé les
gouvernements précédents
tout ça au nom du capitalisme et au nom
de la tête comme si les salariés étaient
responsables de la dette
au sein même de syriza certains accusent
le gouvernement de s'y pressent de se
renier mairie nador ou assument une
ligne plus pragmatique
ce sera la guerre pendant cinq ans mais
nous avons déjà fait un bilan ce que
nous avons fait et il y a déjà des
petites améliorations qui vont nous
mener à des progrès encore plus
important si on voulait faire trop de
choses trop vite on prendrait le risque
de ne plus avancer du tout
difficile pour syriza de trouver le bon
équilibre entre une dette qui interdit
toute marge de manoeuvre et une
population grecque qui attend le respect
des promesses de campagne
syriza à l'épreuve du pouvoir nous en
parlons avec deux invités de députés
européens guillaume balas bonjour
bonjour merci d'être sur ce plateau vous
êtes membre du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates et membre de l'ailé gauche du
parti socialiste français est en face de
vous robert rochefort bonjour alors
cette élite du modem et vous faites
partie du groupe alliance des démocrates
et des libéraux pour l'europe vous êtes
par ailleurs économistes une question de
réaction sur ce reportage finalement on
voit que l' enthousiasme des lendemains
de victoire en janvier en grèce est un
peu retombée devant la réalité des
choses
question est ce que le radical cipra ce
ne serait pas devenu social démocrate
devant les matins c'était ma thèse
depuis le début c'est que en fait syriza
par sa nature n'était pas du tout
l'extrême gauche et que c'était des gens
extrêmement pragmatique et qui sont
aujourd'hui confrontés à des problèmes
considérables
simplement ils correspondent à un
sursaut démocratique qui a eu le peuple
grec et qui aujourd'hui mes phases de
logique en europe très clairement est ce
que l'europe est simplement une alliance
j'allais dire financière et de
compensation financière entre ses
membres ou est-ce que nous sommes
d'abord une union politique et qui
réfléchit comme tel la crise actuelle
notamment de la grèce avec le fmi et de
ce point de vue là exemplaire il va
falloir ils répondent vite autrement il
ya un risque de délitement alors
justement robert rochefort moi j'ai une
question plus générale parce qu'à chaque
fois qu'on se retrouve sur ce plateau on
parle de dernière chance de pays au bord
du gouffre et finalement le temps passe
et la grèce est toujours membre de la
zone euro est-ce que ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est un nouveau coup de
bluff un chantage au défaut de paiement
de la part de la grèce où est ce qu'il
ya un vrai risque cette fois sérieux que
la grèce soit en défaut de paiement dans
les jeux que je pense que la situation
s'aggrave et je pense qu'il faut arrêter
de tirs tous les deux mois que ces
négociations de la dernière chance et si
dans quelques jours la grèce réussi à
rembourser un premier chèque au fmi on
sait très bien que rien ne sera réglé
pour autant je crois que c'est fini
enfin l'époque l'époque où l'on pouvait
dire on continue comme ça de membres la
grèce va très très mal aujourd'hui
l'amélioration compte bhl de la grèce
est purement fondé sur le fait que la
grèce a fait les fonds de tiroirs de
toutes les communes de toutes les
collectivités argent dans les caisses
non je crois qu'il faut maintenant être
raisonnable on est devant un choix qui
est un choix très clair où effectivement
la grèce fait un pas de plus vers des
réformes qui sont des réformes telles
que le fmi le souhaitent est telle qu'un
certain nombre au sein de l'europe le
souhaitent honnêtement je crois que
c'était possible et quelques temps je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement
difficile ou bien il faut avoir le
courage de dire il faut envisager autre
chose parce que l'important c'est pas la
dette
l'important c'est la croissance si on
sauve la dette pendant deux mois mais
que la croissance continue à ne pas être
au rendez vous la grèce va continuer à
s'enfoncer autrement dit comment faire
en sorte que le peuple grec puisse
retrouver un chemin de croissance et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
effectivement se demander si la moins
mauvaise des solutions n'est pas la
sortie de la zone euro alors scénario
une grèce hors de la zone euro alors
d'un pur point de vue économique je peux
comprendre le raisonnement qui serait en
fait un ajustement monétaire de la
situation grecque par sa sortie de la
zone euro je pense que d'un point de vue
politique c'est une catastrophe pourquoi
parce que cela voudrait dire donc que la
zone euro est d'abord aujourd'hui une
zone comme je le disais de solidarité
financière avant d'être une zone
d'intégration politique et comme nous
sommes dans un contexte plus large avec
notamment un royaume uni qui aujourd'hui
va créer des tensions en europe je crois
que tout ce qui va vers l'éclatement de
l'europe est quelque chose de très
difficile pour l'éviter je crois qu'il
est absolument nécessaire aujourd'hui de
changer en effet l approche par rapport
à la grèce est de répondre maintenant de
manière systémique à quel est son
problème économique majeur qui est celui
de la croissance de regarder comment on
fait renaître cette croissance et quand
que la dette et que la dette est déjà de
pas de les tempérer par des
remboursements qui de toute façon
n'aboutiront jamais au remboursement
complet de la dette je rappelle une
chose le fmi qui exigent aujourd'hui des
remboursements a de lui même dit il ya
quelques mois que la manière dont ils
avaient analyser la crise grecque
avaient été faussés par de mauvais
indicateurs ils feraient bien de s'en
souvenir en tout cas le fmi ne dépend
pas de bruxelles ni de l'europe non ça
se trouve on a décidé de mettre le fmi
dans cette affaire et le fmi est le
premier
créancier qui exigent ils exigent des
réformes des red wings et alors là je
dis simplement qu'il faut pas faire
d'amalgamé par rapport à ce qui a été
dit le royaume uni n'est pas dans la
zone euro donc si demain la grèce n'est
pas dans la zone euro ça ne veut pas
dire que la grèce n'est pas dans
l'europe pour l'instant elle il faut oui
on a fait trois erreurs on ne devait pas
faire rentrer la grèce dans un zone euro
on ne devait pas accepter les comptes
truqués quand on les a vus et il ya
quelques années l'europe aurait dû se
prendre autrement pour aider la grèce à
remonter ça n'a pas été le cas
maintenant ça n'a pas été le cas donc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut se dire
qu'il est possible de sortir la grèce de
la zone euro sans que ce soit un drame
et de voir comment on est capable de le
faire de façon intelligente et politique
parce que évidemment on peut dire la
pire des choses en politique c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer par
rapport à la grèce de mois en mois c'est
à dire de laisser croire qu'il y à un
compromis possible et de le trimbaler de
mois en mois parce qu'aujourd'hui il
faut bien voir que par exemple le
gouvernement socialiste où les
représentants de gouvernements
socialistes français lorsqu'ils sont en
négociations avec le groupe technique ou
à bruxelles ils tiennent le même
discours que que le gouvernement
allemand il tient le même discours que
le fmi quand vous entendez monsieur par
exemple ce sapin il dit qu'il faut
encore plus de réformes en grèce
autrement dit une sorte de discours
unanime qui recouvre quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui ne me semble pas être en
mesure de permettre à la grèce de
redémarrer sa croissance si elle ne
redémarre pas sa croissance on a tous
perdus et la pauvreté qu'on a vu dans un
avantage on va continuer à progresser du
taur ghirda ya risque il ya
effectivement deux discours du parti
socialiste fin pour bruxelles et un
autre en français et son adresse c'est
pas c'est pas le parti socialiste est en
général il peut y avoir en effet les
discours des états en interne aux états
et
leur population qui après ce qui se dit
ici c'est une pratique malheureuse mais
habituel je crois qu'en effet il faut
qu'aujourd'hui la gauche est un oui il
vous faudrait qu aujourd'hui la gauche
aux européennes d'arbres et
qu'aujourd'hui la gauche européenne soit
clair sur le sujet suivant c est ce que
nous considérons que la nature même de
la zone euro est simplement encore une
fois j'allais dire une zone monétaire
économique qui n'a d'autre destin qu une
solidarité financière entre ses membres
ou est ce que nous voulons un destin
politique si nous voulons un destin
politique pour la zone euro ça veut dire
que nous sommes en capacité de compenser
les différences économiques entre ses
états et sa demande évidemment du point
de vue de la construction de la zone
euro un outil nouveau qui soit un outil
d'ajustement d'investissements publics
d'ajustement budgétaire faire de la
politique aujourd'hui avec la zone euro
ça veut dire lutter contre le chômage ça
veut dire créer des emplois ça veut dire
faire en sorte qu aider la croissance
qui redémarre or aujourd'hui 2 fait
parce que les situations économiques ne
sont pas les mêmes dans les différents
pays de la zone euro alors on ne peut
pas faire de la même façon dont les pays
justement je vous propose d'écouter à ce
sujet ce cas nous dira l'élu de syriza
qu'on a rencontrés dans notre reportage
elle croit avoir un autre chemin pour la
grèce et pour l'europe écoutez
ce
qui dépasse son pays on ne se bat pas
seulement pour la grèce mais pour toute
l'union européenne
et c'est pour cela que l'on subit une
pression aussi énorme en fait le dilemme
est simple soit alexis tsipras c'est le
gouvernement syriza gagne et à ce moment
là nous aurons la construction
européenne que nous voulons soit alexis
tsipras c'est series à perdre et alors
nous n'aurons pas de construction
européenne dit
guillaume balas pour répondre à ce qu'on
vient d'entendre une bataille toujours
ouverte entre partisans et opposants de
l'austérité n'y a pas de troisième voie
possible entre
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je crois que
l'union européenne abe a compris sa
faute originelle de 2008 et notamment
d'avoir une mené mener une politique
absurde et qui nous a amené près de la
déflation il ya une prise de conscience
de cela à travers un certain nombre
d'outils nouveaux à travers la baisse de
l'euro la politique monétaire que nous
menons néanmoins c'est très nettement
insuffisant oui il faut prendre un
chemin aujourd'hui très différent du
point de vue économique si on veut
recréer des conditions de la croissance
et donc de la transition vers le monde
nouveau qui vient non mais on peut pas
ne pas avoir cent soixante dix pour cent
de dettes publiques dans un état en
considérant que c'est la faute des
autres
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui est aussi la
faute des grecs c'est la faute des
européens qui sonne aussi la faute des
rings est en réalité nous ne pouvons pas
faire comme si cette dette publique dans
les différents états on pouvait passer
l'épongé comme sur une ardoise de talent
aux places arrières petites questions
avant de conclure cette émission très de
manière très courte est-ce que vous
pensez que alexis tsipras sera poussé
vers la sortie comme on était soit on
prédécesseur georges papandréou est
aussi l'italien berlusconi à l'époque
d'un gala merkel et de nicolas sarkozy
est ce que ça peut être moins je crois
pas ça parce que je pense que il essaye
ce qui est est la grande différence avec
les gouvernements précédents en grèce et
comme ils essayent de résister même
s'ils ne réussissent pas tout je pense
que le soutien populaire à syriza va
continuer longtemps même si évidemment
il faudra aussi des réussites ont pour
le consolider la longère je crois qu'il
faut qu' il faut que ce gouvernement
tienne un discours clair à son peuple or
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas et
peut-être que le référendum qu'il
envisage éventuellement de faire sera
une réponse est ce que il veut rentrer
dans ce que lui propose l'union
européenne s'il le fait le peuple grec
le suivra ou pas je ne sais pas et si
non quelles propositions il fait mille
peut pas dire je veux rester dans la
zone euro en même temps vos propositions
ne sont pas des propositions acceptables
et puis de mois en mois d'affaiblir est
d'abord ouvrir l'ensemble des
collectivités du peuple grec merci à
vous de nous avoir donné votre point de
vue sur ce casse-tête grecs on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine très 26 de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires et sur la rtbf bail